le mali en pleine transition après le
coup d'état de mardi la junte affirme
vouloir une transition la plus courte
possible
le comité national pour le salut du
peuple affiche son souhait de nommer un
président pour assurer le pouvoir durant
cette période le temps d'organiser des
élections mais pour les militaires
maliens
il ne s'agit pas d'un coup d'état au
coup d'état c'est quoi c'est une
interruption de l'ordre constitutionnel
à ma connaissance d'autres concessions
délinquants glace ça veut dire quoi
qu'il a conçu et là ça veut dire quoi
le président il a dissous l'assemblée
nationale
ça fait partie de ses prérogatives en
tant que chef d'état quand la
constitution
il a démis des gouvernements ça fait
partie c'est pratiquement tarie chef de
l'état enfin il a signé cette émission
ça fait partie des prérogatives de chef
d'état et la constitution toujours là et
tout est dans le cadre constitutionnel
car je ne suis pas d'accord que c'est un
coup d'état
c'est une c'est quelque chose qui s'est
passé et les gens ont constaté la
démission du vin son président alors que
les pays voisins avait à la suite du
putsch décidé de fermer leurs frontières
terrestres et aériennes
le cnsp a annoncé la réouverture de
celle ci à compter de ce vendredi
quant à la communauté économique des
états de l'afrique de l'ouest
elle exige le retour d'ibrahim boubacar
keita à la présidence nous demande de
l'établissement du ps 2 et vin nouveau
calque état en tant que président de la
république conformément aux dispositions
constitutionnelles de son pays nous
allons encore en discussion avec les
responsables de la junte militaire pour
leur porter le message de notre
communauté
la prise de pouvoir par les militaires
ne convainc guère au sein de la classe
politique malienne et des syndicats qui
condamne ce coup de force
le présent
le premier ministre et toutes les
personnalités arrêtées doivent être
remises en liberté sans condition et
dans la même dynamique qui les invite à
accélérer le processus de libérations de
l'honorable soumaïla cissé jeunesse et
le mal et nous sommes là comme on aime à
le dire un peu plus à s'assumer aussi
face à nos problèmes et à nos
responsabilités et nous demandera à ce
que la communauté internationale dans
son ensemble au lieu de prendre des
singes contre le peuple malien qui
cherchent tout simplement à résoudre ses
propres problèmes plutôt que cette
communauté internationale consiste le
peuple manille ont lieu de les poser
pour paris ce renversement sonne comme
un revers dans la lutte contre le
djihadisme au sahel
ib cas étant jusqu'ici l'un des
principaux interlocuteurs de la france
dans ce combat